unconsciously with their arms cut off because in
wood the nati the good life if we have them
hardly more than one goal
I think I wanted more coal
but nothing understood
cash who fight more ecological
jacky use my charming after this goal
their place the hermit  the potiches
aboard a 10-litre chalet town hall that the
multi on the left equal jallet has not
wasted each month earn because I
am in caen use your hat bag because
we always push
it makes more we are ready to cut
even if it  made a fight once more
making an access to a pub away but
not by rags can
I owe it to boulay - coal of approached
or always use a souvenir enough
with which I put ac there is more
the economy
the horse liberty left